après la sortie du royaume uni merci la
parole et à monsieur alain suguenot
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
défense monsieur le ministre un grand
quotidien national titrait ce week-end
nous bombardons dahesh en irak et en
syrie mais nous sommes incapables de
contrôler nos banlieues
au delà de la question de l'opportunité
est ce raisonnable voire efficace de se
lancer dans des offensives comme à
mossoul
lorsque nous sommes incapables d'assurer
la sécurité sur d'autres territoires il
faut bien sûr qu'on bat deich par tous
les moyens
nous savons pertinemment que ce n'est
pas la france qui libéra mossoul chez le
ministre les renforts venus de me soule
ne risque-t-il pas de relancer depuis la
syrie la campagne d'europe au coeur de
la stratégie transnationale de dèche
ce n'est pas tant d'irak le terrorisme
se développe vous le savez bien c'est à
partir de la syrie que djihadisme
prolifèrent c'est en syrie qui doit être
terrassé avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
monsieur le ministre ne pouvons plus
nous permettre d'attendre le prochain
attentat et de défiler en condamnant le
terrorisme
selon les experts la bataille de mossoul
sera longue l'issue en sera incertaine
et le drame humain qui s'ensuivra risque
de créer là aussi d'autres difficultés
dont imaginons pas encore les
conséquences
notre priorité au delà du symbole de
présence aux côtés des vainqueurs
potentiels de mossoul doit bien sûr être
de protéger d'autres territoires
quand on fait la guerre on doit assumer
les conséquences
les djihadistes ne se pose pas cette
question nous nous devons être garant de
la sécurité de nos concitoyens mais
celle ministre pouvez-vous nous rassurer
sur ce point
merci la parole l'état monsieur jean
yves le drian minutes va la défense
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
suguenot le premier ministre irakien
monsieur abadie a décidé il ya deux
jours le lancement de l'offensive contre
la capitale de dèche mossoul
c'est la capitale de dèche donc le lieu
où se sont organisés fomenté décidé les
attentats qui ont été commis en france
c'est la capitale de neige
notre ennemi et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous combattons en appuyant les
forces irakiennes et défense peshmerga
dans leur détermination à reconquérir
mossoul
c'est une
sion de sécurité pour notre territoire
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes actifs et nous sommes déterminés
à l'accompagnement jusqu'à l'éradication
de neige sur ce territoire
c'est vrai que ça ne règle pas tout mais
il faut d'abord touché le centre
éliminer le centre pour pouvoir ensuite
continuer à s'attaquer aux métastases
alors cette bataille c'est vrai sera
longue pour trois raisons d'abord parce
que c'est la capitale de déchets donc
qui se sont organisés en ligne de
défense rigoureuse en disant des
souterrains en piégeant les entrées de
ville elle sera longue parce que la
population est importante un million
cinq cent mille habitants
elle sera longue aussi parce que nous
avons des règles d'engagement
extrêmement précises pour éviter les
dégâts collatéraux et ses règles
d'engagement seront scrupuleusement
respecté pendant toute cette bataille
et puis enfin nous avons pris les moyens
nécessaires pour assurer les conditions
humanitaires minimum puisque 750 mille
places de réfugiés sont organisées aux
alentours de mossoul
mais monsieur le député la bataille
contre le terrorisme elle commence
d'abord là bas merci la séance des
questions au gouvernement sur des sujets
européens ont terminé la séance est
suspendue